give you an update on the latest data
from the Cobra coronavirus data file and
I can report that through the
government's ongoing monitoring and
testing program as of today 559
have now been tested for the virus one
hundred and thirty three thousand four
hundred and ninety five have tested
positive and are those who have
contracted the virus
18100 have very sadly died and we
express our deepest condolences to the
families and friends of these victims
and my heart goes out to every single
one of those who have lost a loved one
throughout this crisis as a government
we continue to take the steps necessary
to slow the spread of this virus the
social distancing measures that people
have overwhelmingly adhered to have
meant that fewer people have needed
hospital treatment that has protected
our NHS capacity as we continue through
the peak of this virus and it has
undoubtedly helped to save lives at
every point in this crisis we've
considered the scientific and the
medical evidence that we received very
carefully and we've been deliberate in
our actions so that we take the right
steps at the right time now I know it's
been tough going tough going for
businesses for families for vulnerable
members of our communities up and down
the country and it's been a physical
strain as we adapt to living and working
at home while not seeing our family and
our friends in the usual way we would
like to it's been an economic strain as
businesses have had to furlough staff
which is why the chance to launch the
various business support measures to
help see businesses and workers through
these difficult times but it's also been
an immense mental strain on everyone
people stuck at home
families worried about their finances
and the elderly more isolated than we'd
ever want them to be we are making
progress through the preak of this virus
but we're not out of the woods yet as
Sage advised last week that's why the
measures we introduced must remain in
place for the time being
the greatest risk for us now if we used
up on our social distancing rules too
soon is that we would risk a second
spike in the virus with all the threats
to life that that would bring and then
the risk of a second lockdown which
would prolong the economic pain that
we're all going through and that was a
point that Andrew Bailey the governor of
the Bank of England also made earlier on
today so with that in mind last Thursday
I set out the five principles that will
guide our approach going forward to the
next phase and which must be satisfied
before we were willing and in a position
to make any changes which will of course
be based on the advice that we receive
from Sage that way we will ensure that
our path out of this crisis is
sure-footed protecting both the public's
health but also our economy if we stick
to our plan if we take the right steps
at the right time we can get through
this crisis and I know we will there's
no hiding the scale of this tragedy but
even in our darkest moments the crisis
has also shown a light on the best
amongst us and the nation has come
together to applaud our heroic NHS staff
our carers every week and we pay tribute
to their dedication their
professionalism and the care with which
they look after those who have fallen
sick and with general Carter here today
I think it's only fitting to pay tribute
to the amazing work of our fantastic
Armed Forces and their whole MOT led by
defense secretary Ben Wallace they have
been there every step of the way helping
us to build the new NHS Nightingale
Nightingale hospitals to reinforce our
critical care capacity supporting our
local resilience forums in delivering
personal protective equipment where it's
needed most and helping also to deliver
the mobile labs which are critical to
ramping up our testing capacity right
across the country and as a result of
those efforts and that teamwork
hospitals have been able to treat more
patients as a result they save more
lives and we've ensured that the peak of
this virus has not overwhelmed the NHS
and today our armed forces are again
part of that team as we announced two
new deployments to the NHS Nightingale
facilities in Harrogate and Bristol and
across the UK this extra Hospital
capacity which itself comes on top of
the 33,000 additional beds we've managed
to free up across the NHS that's the
equivalent of building an extra 50
district general hospitals and as I said
that has safeguarded the capacity in our
hospitals both to care for coronavirus
patients but also to make sure other
people get the urgent care or the
emergency treatment they need we've used
a joke in this country that you could
never build a hospital that quickly well
we didn't just build one we built seven
and we thank our armed forces for
helping to make that happen and you know
for many countries around the world
including modern democracies the sight
of their military on the streets and a
national emergency could be a cause for
concern or even trepidation but for the
British people the sight of our armed
forces working side by side with our
brilliant NHS staff offers a calm
reassurance the task is at hand and that
we will come through this crisis now I
make no bones about it there have been
challenges there still are challenges
we're not there yet
we continue to ramp up the testing
capacity which will play a really
important role in the next phase of the
crisis amidst a global shortage in
personal protective equipment we've
distributed over a billion items to the
frontline where it's needed most we've
just brought in Lord Dayton who helped
organise the London Olympics that boost
our domestic supply even further and I'm
on the phone every day pursuing the next
batch of deliveries from abroad with the
support of our tireless diplomatic
service and the first of several new
deliveries landed from Turkey in the
early hours this morning we will only
come through this global pandemic if we
come together as a nation and if we
bring other countries around the world
together so that we can rise to this
international challenge and as we work
with our partners abroad to get the PPE
we need to get their ventilators we need
to pursue a vaccine for this terrible
virus we're also working night and day
to return stranded
Nationals from all four corners of the
world we kept airports open and Airlines
running to bring over a million Brits
home on commercial flights a massive
endeavor and on top of that at the FCO
we set up a 75 million pound special
Charter arrangement with the airlines
and that's already brought home over
13,000 people on 63 flights from more
than a dozen countries a more organizing
more charter flights in the days ahead
from India Pakistan Bangladesh New
Zealand Nigeria and Sierra Leone so at
home and abroad we're meeting the whole
range of challenges that coronavirus
presents and if we stick together and if
we stay the course we will defeat this
virus for good